and then I started hearing really weird
things going all around the internet and
I'm like guys I'm here like that's not
that's not true outbreaks and you're
dying it's rained why is everybody so
concerned I kept thinking am I missing
something now when it got real like when
I understood that something needed to be
done was I think it was Saturday
afternoon and I'm like okay listen
they're telling us we might be here till
Wednesday some of us have RVs a lot of
people don't and if you're in a tent and
your attempt is destroyed flooded you
don't have electricity water clothes or
food if the airspace is locked which it
was and the airport is closed and exits
are closed how long can we really last
like that and that's when I started
going into the mode we got to do
something here there's a problem